last Wednesday off the coast of Greece the
sea swallowed the bodies and lives of
several hundred men, women
and children of exiles who were trying to
survive better elsewhere this is
one of the deadliest shipwrecks
ever  seen in the Mediterranean it is estimated
that there are around 600 dead
including around a hundred children drowned
with their mother in the hold of their
boat coffin in their memory I propose to you
dear colleagues ladies and
gentlemen ministers that we
observe a minute of  silence
I find that indeed this
idea is wonderful but the Conference
of Presidents is there for that so that
we can collectively decide on
the moments in which in this
program we honor the
missing people we do not do two minutes of
silence in this way  you should
know that I am sorry and I am
sorry that you force me to make this
kind of comment yes it is sad because
these are moments which should
unite us and not disunite us and
practices such as these
dishonors us, I am sorry,
good Mr. Caron, would you
like to continue your question,
thank you,
I do not see why the improvisation
of this moment would prevent the Union